ا ضربه محتمله
للحوثيين يامل اصحابها الا تؤدي لاتساع
نطاق الحرب يعني كيف على اي اساس يبنون
هذا
التصور اهلا بك زين وساده المشاهدين اعتقد
التصور خاطئ الى حد بعيد يعني هذا ما يطلق
عليه ديفيت ذا ببز يعني هم الان يهزمون
منطقهم بانفسهم عندما يقوم او تقوم قوات
بعمليات عسكريه نوعيه تجاه دوله اخرى هذا
يعني اعلان الحرب نحن اذاء انتظار لاعلان
الحرب من قبل بريطانيا وامريكا على اليمن
على الحوثيين تحديدا هذا الامر ياتي في
اطار عده اعتبارات في ظني حركت هذا
الموضوع طبعا نحن كنا نتوقع ذلك خلال
الفتره الماضيه وقنا اكثر من مره نحن اذاء
عمليه تحشد تحشيد وتعبئه في البحر الاحمر
لكن الذي عجل بذلك اعتقد عده امور الامر
الاول اولا صدور قرار بالامس من مجلس
الامن القرار 27 22 والذي يدين هجمات
الحوثيين ويطالب بوقفها بشكل فو
ويعطي الحق للدول التي لديها سفن هناك
بالدفاع عن النفس طبعا هذا يعتبر غطاء قد
يتم تفسيره باعتباره اعطاء الشرعيه له
لهذا العمل لكن فيضن طبعا هذا غ غير صحيح
لانه هذا لا يعطي التحالف الازدهار اي نوع
من الشرعيه بنتكلم فقط على دولتين هم
بريطانيا وامريكا الامر الاخر اعتقد مرتبط
بالهجوم النوعي اللي وقع يعني ليله امس
وهو هجوم معقد من خلال 18 مسيره اثنين
صاروخ كروز وصاروخ بالستي وتم التصدي لها
من خلال اربع مدمرات الثلاثه منها امريكيه
والرابعه بريطانيه الامر الثالث المهم
اعتقد مرتبط بجوله بلينكن على ما يبدو انه
ابلغ او حذر الدول الاقليميه خاصه الحلفاء
في المنطقه من امكانيه القيام بهجوم نوعي
ضد الحوثيين خاصه في ظل ما تم اعطاه قبل
اسبوع من التمتم او تحذير قوي جدا من بعض
الدول الحوثيين بوقف هجماتهم ولس يتم
التدخل ضدهم وبالتالي نحن اذاء تطور
للصراع بانتظار ساعه الصفر الامر متعلق
كما قال المراسل الزميل من لندن ليس ليس
هل سيحدث ام لا بل متى سيحدث وما هو نطاقه
كما جاء في الاخبار بيتكلموا على استهداف
ل مواقع اسلحه
مسيرات مخازن ذخيره التحد الرئيس الزين
بنتكلم على ان بعض الاسلحه موجود في مناطق
كثف كثفه السكان وبالتالي نتوقع وقوع
ضحايا من المدنيين وهذا يعتبر في حد ذاته
جريمه اخرى تضاف لسل الجرا طيب مرد
المتوقع يعني اذا كان فقط هو استهداف
لمنشات دون وقوع خسائر بشريه ما الرد
المتوقع من الحوثيين في هذه الحاله واذا
حدثت خسائر بشريه خاصه في صب المدنيين ما
ايضا ما الرد المتوقع اولا ليس هناك
ضمانات زين بعدم وقوع ضحايا مدنيين نتكلم
على اذا صح ما جاء في الاخبار اليوم انه
تم نقل بعض الزخار والاسلحه والمسيرات
باتجاه مناطق كثفه السكان وبالتالي اي
ضربات نوعيه تاتي من البحر من قبل صواريخ
يتم اطلاقها او مسيرات امريكيه و بريطانيه
على مواقع داخل اليمن بالقطع سيكون ضحيتها
مدنيين وهذا الامر يعني صعب جدا يتم
تفاديه في اطار مطلق عليه كلات دامج يعني
فده نمره نمره واحد نمره اثنين ما يتعلق
بالنتائج طبعا نتائج ستكون كارثيه وخيمه
ودعني اعدد بعضها اولا نتكلم على حرب
مفتوحه على كل سناريوهات هناك امكانيات
للحوثيين لضرب مصالح امريكا وبريطانيا
بنتكلم على حركه لديها مسيرات لديها
صواريخ بالستيه صواريخ كروز لديها قدره
على الوصول
ل عمق البحار البحر الاحمر لديها زوارق
مسيره وتم تم يعني استخدام بعضها قبل فتره
ده من الناحيه العسكريه وبالتالي احنا لو
بنتكلم عن الهدف من هذه العمليه هو حفظ
الامن نحن اذاء العكس تماما هذا يؤدي الى
عدم استقرار المنطقه يعدي الى يؤدي العدم
وجود امن في هذه المنطقه يعدي قد يؤدي
ايضا لاغلاق كام
لمضيق باب المندب وبالتالي وقف الملاحه
العالميه والتجاريه بشكل كامل الامر الاخر
قد يؤدي الى استفزاز فاعلين اخرين خاصه
ايران وبنتكلم على منطقه حيويه جدا وال
اليوم راينا احتجاز ايران لسفينه تقول ان
سفينه كانت تبيعه لها وتم احتجازها من
امريكا قبل اربع سنوات من الان او ثلاث
سنوات من الان في في 2021